okay so thanks for coming everyone I so
I'm gonna follow on about hypothesis
test day we're gonna be talking about
simple hypothesis testing in this at
this joint work with Clement come on
cannon come on Adam Smith and John Alden
all of who are here with varying density
this week in the semester okay
so Jordan just talked about hypothesis
testing let's do a little bit of a
review so what does testing happens
everywhere in statistics so we have here
our data analyst and she wants to know
the answer to some yes or no question
and what way she might try and answer
this question is to construct it as a
hypothesis test so a hypothesis test I
had some space of distribution so I
think my population could possibly be
drawn from I have two sets might not let
thought this is set and my alternate
hypothesis but I destroyed subsets of my
space of distributions and the job of a
hypothesis test is to take some number
of samples from some distribution art
and decide with high probability whether
are belong to in the null hypothesis or
the alternate hypothesis and these tests
are ubiquitous since difference add
because they form an alliance or no
questions about an underlying population
based on tables okay so my I did I
almost here one to know I do at least
fifty percent of people support
Democrats insert your favorite yes I
know they do I'm out analysis question
but what she could have asked is just is
the part of the probability that someone
supports the Democrats fifty percent or
is it forty nine percent and foremost
hypothesis tests if she answers this
question she will have also answered the
previous question and this is a simpler
kind of hypothesis test and aptly named
a simple hypothesis test so in a simple
hypothesis test my null space in my hypo
and my alternate space are just
singleton sets so I have two
distributions P and Q and I'm just
trying to decide whether the samples I
get come from P or they come from you
and why we care about sympathises
testing is there a couple of reasons so
what is that we can see that many
compass IPOP see so compass a hypothesis
is just
we're hate shoulder each one are not
singleton sighs many compiz hypotheses
can be reduced to simple hypothesis
hypotheses and because that's the
simplest type of hypothesis testing
lower bands for simple hypothesis
testing are going to apply for a
composite hypothesis testing and they
also arise in lower bounds for
estimation problems okay so this slide
is a little bit preaching to the choir
here but it's often desirable for
statistical tests to be stable under
small changes in the data so one of the
reasons we care about this is privacy uh
and a nice line of work done by several
people in this room so we might also
care about this if we care about
generalize a trend realizability under
adaptive data analysis okay unless you
missed every talk this semester you
probably know this definition we're
gonna be talking about pure differential
privacy today so a test is epsilon
differentially private if given two
databases the different a single element
for any given output the probability of
that output under if the input was X is
about the same as probably it that
output if they even put with X Prime and
what is nice about testing is that the
optimal sample complexity for it's the
same for pure differential privacy
approximate differential privacy and
hence any stability notions in between
and these include concentrated deep ekl
stability and twelve relations is to the
stability so while I'm gonna focus day
and phrase everything in terms of
epsilon period differential privacy all
of the bounds I'm going to say also hold
for these other notions of stability
okay so as we've seen there's been a lot
of work I'm probably hypothesis testing
so some of these focus on producing
differentially private versions of
popular statistical tests such as
goodness-of-fit closeness and
independence some focus on small sample
sizes and this focus on asymptotic
sample complexity which is what we're
going to talk about today and most of
these are in the central model and
they're some work in the local model
well it may be different about this work
is if we're going to give an instant
specific sample complexity so that p and
Q we're trying to distinguish between
the simple complexity we're gonna give
is in terms of P and Q and as far as we
know this is the first work that gives
instant an instant specific
characterization of sample complexity in
the central model I in the local model
do Chi Jordan min Wayne right give it in
some specific characterization for the
same problem for simple hypothesis
testing in the local model and we'll
talk a little bit more about there is
all a little later
towards the instance
at the specific pinky we choose
okay so if don't kind of intuitively
about what I thought this is testing is
so let's get into what it actually means
kind of mathematically so we say a test
is going to distinguish between our
distributions P and Q yes give it a
sample that really was from P it should
output P with probability 2/3 and given
a sample that really was from Q it
should output Q in probability 2/3 if
jr. X doesn't seem very high to you we
can amplify this to any constant with a
constant factor increase in our sample
complexity and I said this word sample
complexity a few times so the sample
complexity of a test is the smallest and
such that if I have a database of at
least that size my test always works at
distinguishing between being Q so do I
satisfies these two things MSA test has
optimal sample complexity if example
complexity is Big O of any other test
okay so I'm talking about asymptotic
sample complexity
okay so today we're talking about
private simple hypothesis testing so
everything kind of remains the same on
this slide except for the blue things so
we're now going to require our tests to
the epsilon differentially private I'm
gonna put this little epsilon on my
sample complexity what I mean the
private simple complexity and now of
course I'm gonna call it a test I have
optimal private optimal sample Exedy for
a private test I'm only gonna compare to
other private tests and so a big part of
the question today is going to be how
does this sample complexity change when
I change epsilon or put an epsilon in at
all and how does the form of the test
change okay so two main contributions of
this work so the first one is we're
going to characterize characterize the
optimal sample complexity for privately
distinguishing between P and Q this is
for any distributions we do require them
to have PDFs but other than that we have
no requirements and we're gonna give
actually to optimal efficient tests so
two tests that satisfy that achieve this
simple complexity I have a star in the
efficiency here because there's one
little caveat to how efficient they are
and we'll talk about that a little later
along the way we're gonna give a noble
interpretation of the Hellinger distance
which is going to give us some insight
into the non favorite setting in the
paper but I'm not going to talk about it
today we give that location of a
hypothesis testing result to epsilon
differentially private change point
detection
what any questions so far okay so before
we get into the private result let's
talk about the non private solution so
if you're given a database and you want
to decide where that came from P or Q
and you don't care about privacy what
you should do is just output a P if it
was more likely to have occurred under P
then Q and Q otherwise and if Amos this
neyman-pearson mama the Jordan mentioned
says that this is has exactly optimal
skip the complexity so notice I have
this word exactly here because there
really is no tests that's better than
this simple complexity has this neat
characterization so its sample
complexity is determined by its 1 over
the Hellinger distance squared so how we
define the Hellinger distance is if I
take my distributions P and Q I take
that point wise square root they look
like on the unit circle and the
Hellinger distance is the Euclidean
distance between the square root of
these distributions so if you don't have
a lot of intuition for this part of what
we're going to talk about in this work
is giving some intuition of why this
particular distribution occurs or this
particular metric occurs in the
hypothesis testing problem
okay so one thing I want to do first is
I define this test before this is kind
of the most obvious thing you could do
but I actually want to rephrase it like
this where I have a test statistic my
I'm gonna call the log likelihood ratio
and I make some decision based on my
test statistic so when my testa SiC is
is it just takes every day to point and
take the ratio of P or Q take the log of
that and sums them all up this is
exactly equal to the log of PN of my big
database x over Q NFI big data basics
and so this thing is bigger than 0 that
means that P was but X is more likely
under P so I stop for P and if less than
0 then the same for Q so this test is
exactly the same as the test I just
described it just has this test
statistic that's gonna be a useful way
of writing my tests ok so the real
reason why the name will kiss and LEM is
gonna be so famous is because this is a
really helpful lever if you're trying to
do actual hypothesis testing so it means
that you should if you can you should
definitely do this love likelihood test
them you shouldn't worry about doing
anything else so our goal for today is
going to obtain an analogous result for
private hypothesis testing
so so an outline in fact hook so we're
gonna state the main theorem always
helpful in a talk and I previously come
in three parts so the first thing we're
gonna do is give some insight into the
non private test this is going to tell
us a little bit about how we should
construct our private test and then
we're gonna do an upper bound and a
lower bond and we'll talk more about how
they're actually gonna go a little later
okay so this is not quite sure I'm
actually going to lead up to the
statement of the theorem so first let's
talk about what your first guess of this
thing might be so this thing is easy to
prove that it's a lower bound so my my
privates up of LexA T is definitely
bigger than this and I have my nonprofit
sample complexity plus one over epsilon
times the total variation distance and
why this says lower order here it's
because if I got rid of this epsilon
this first term would always dominate
the second term and this is the kind of
form of sample complexities we see often
in privacy that we have the non private
sample complexity plus some term that
depends on epsilon so turns out that for
Bernoulli distributions
I've upper bound also holds and this
formula characterizes the optimal
private sample complexity and this is
really nice because it applies several
things so the first one is in a place of
phase transition so it means that if
epsilon is bigger then your Hellinger
distance squared divided by your total
radiation distance they do go privacy
for free what I mean by privacy for free
is that your private sample complexity
varies s methodically in the same way is
your non private sample complexity and
even if you don't reach that threshold
so if the epsilon is less than this
thing you still get a second term but
your second term just and then described
as a lower order so its dependence on P
and Q is lower than the first term
okay so it'd be great if I held in
general but unfortunately that nice
characterization doesn't even hold when
we go up to size three universes so here
I have my P and my Q and my P is just
uniform of my second two coordinates and
my Q takes a little bit of the mass from
here and moves it onto my first element
so this nice formula we had before can
now be written like this but the actual
sample complexity is given by the
minimum of these two terms so this first
term comes basically from waiting until
you see it element from a or you can
tell these for an element for it and the
second term comes from telling between
these two distributions restricted to B
and C and this one can be arbitrarily
larger than this huh and the easiest way
to see that is imagine setting epsilon 2
square root alpha then these two terms
both scale like 1 over alpha squared and
there's no term that scales
whatever alpha squared in this hole so
we get a very different um asymptotic
behavior for the private test
okay so now we've kind of rolled out a
simple characterization let's move on to
standing the main theorem so this is
gonna take a little bit so let's start
first with what our test statistic is so
remember before I cut statistic we
called the log likelihood ratio and it's
basically the same as this but we didn't
have these square brackets what I'm
gonna do now is for each data point I'm
gonna clamp the log likelihood ratio
between epsilon and this number right
now negative epsilon prime I'm gonna
talk about what epsilon prime is in a
second but basically if it's too big
what it was to to slow soup that you
were in P we're just gonna kind of scale
its influence back down and suddenly if
it was to disclose to you that you were
in Q you're gonna scale it back up okay
so what does that slim Prime
so I have P Q here nicely my universe is
nicely rescaled we have a nice picture
here and the first thing I'm gonna do is
this blue dotted line is the minimum of
P and even the epsilon Q and the red
dotted line is the same thing with pink
you and the important thing about these
dotted lines is that their ratio never
exceeds either the epsilon so it's
between e to the negative solidity the
epsilon and what I'm gonna do is take
the bigger of these two areas and I'm
gonna call the bigger one tap I know
what some prime is is because this area
is smaller I'm gonna keep decreasing
this exponent until I get area of tau
here okay I can definitely do that and
that it's gonna be epsilon right so
notice that this lower blue dotted line
and the red dotted line still have the
property that their ratio is bounded
between even the negative epsilon and
even Beatrice
okay so now we have our test statistic
every night two tests that are both
gonna turn out to be optimal so our
first test gonna call this soft clamp
the likelihood test and it's basically
the exponential mechanism where the
clamp the likely ratio our test
statistic is my utility function so if
this thing is bigger than zero then this
output speed with high probably than Q
and if this thing is less than zero it
outputs Q with ability bigger than P
which is the behavior we kind of want to
emulate from the non-private test the
noisy clamp will likely a test is an
application of the Plescia mechanism so
we use a glass noise to our test
statistic and then we do basically the
non private test we're gonna put zero if
it's bigger Apple P if it's bigger than
zero an apple Q if it's less than zero
and again we have the behavior that it's
the test statistic is bigger than zero
yeah put P more often than we have with
Q and the reverse if it's negative okay
so we're gonna focus mainly on this test
today they actually both of these tests
i've optimal sample Alexa T
by focusing tight aren't they with
roughly the same thing
yes they're capturing very similar ideas
yeah then but the problem you just
usually about the same how the a
sufficiently good they're not identical
yet
okay
so I'm a theorem is that both of these
tests are have optimal sample complexity
among private tests I me also have this
characterization of the sample
complexity okay so what is this sir our
denominator is epsilon tau so where the
Tau is this area here plus one minus tau
times the hell of your distance between
P prime Akiba what if he prime acutely
so P prime we're gonna take this blue
dotted line and we're gonna normalize it
so it's on my vision constant is 1 minus
tau and that's the new distribution we
call P Prime and the same thing for the
red dotted line we normalize it and that
becomes Q Prime
so the rest in the talk I'm going to
assume that epsilon is equal to epsilon
Prime the proof doesn't really change at
all if I don't assume that I've drove to
carry around this epsilon prime why are
we reducing epsilon epsilon prime to
make their is equal yeah so what's gonna
come down to in the proof is that I
really want these areas to be well
because I want these normalization
constants to be the same we actually
conjecture that you don't the test is
still optimal if you don't do that if
you just two between negative epsilon
maps lies um but we'll see multiple
times in the actual analysis that we
really do need that
okay so let's do some sanity checking
compared to some previous balance so we
always have the private sample
complexity should be bigger than the non
private sample complexity and this is
true also for testing problems we can a
sub sample and aggregate to say that the
private sample complexity should never
exceed 1 over epsilon times the non
private sample complexity which is also
true here and we have one final man to
compare to so this is the stucci Jordan
and Wainwright he'd been referred to
earlier so they prove that the optimal
sample complexity for locally
differentially private tests he is given
by this formula here and we know that
because we're considering a super set of
local differential primes tests our
sample complexity should be better which
it is so check
so we stated my main theorem now so
before we go into kind of the mean of
the proof let's talk about this
fictional test that's gonna give us some
intuition for the proof so what I'm
gonna do is write P and Q is mixtures
remember 1 minus tau P Prime it's
exactly this blue dotted line and one of
my stuff u prime is exactly the red
dotted line and so to get from that
thing to Pete what need to do is
basically add in this green part here so
P double prime is going to be a
distribution that's whose support or is
supported on just this part of my space
similarly Q prime is going to be only
supported on this part of my space
they've destroyed support so now imagine
that you've got your sample from either
P or Q and you were given the additional
information that miss group of samples
came from P double prime of P double
prime and this group of samples came
from P prime or cute right
so this first problem of deciding
whether it's P double prime of Q double
right because they have disjoint support
non privately you only need one point to
decide between them so privately I need
one over epsilon points to decide
between and decide between P Prime and Q
prime these are actually we'll see this
a little bit later but this is designed
so that I get privacy for free which is
kind of gonna be the first step backward
so what that means is that the sample
complexity to determine them is 1 over
the hell on your distance square root of
P Prime
and so together so remember this was our
sample complexity before and we can
rewrite this as the minimum of these two
terms or this first term comes from
determining between Pido or kind of
cute' okay and the second term from P
Prime and Q Prime so as soon as you
solve one of these problems you've
decided between P and Q this is that
fictional test so the purpose are they
come in three parts
so the key inside is going to be this
privacy for free for P Prime and Q Prime
the second part is our lower bound says
that you really do need to be able to
solve one of these tests to be able to
decide between P and Q and the upper
bound so we're under this fictional test
has this extra information of the labels
of which part of them extreme came from
and the block around is gonna basically
say that the noisy clamp likelihood test
captures that test without the need for
labels so it's gonna have the same
simple complexity as this additional
let's move on to looking at the
non-private test so indeed this notion
here of an advantage of a test so some
test that takes in a database and
outputs a decision P and Q its advantage
is defined as the the probability with
true positive minus the probability of
false positive the probability given a
sample from P it does output P minus the
probability given a sample from Q it
accidentally outputs P and a test the
distinguishes pain pink you are it's
House distinguishes pinkie between P and
Q if and only if its advantage is bigger
than 2/3 so there's two conditions I had
before it can just be a real place to
lose this one condition
this term is bigger than 2/3
okay remember this is the non private
test we had before so we tweak produce
test statistic and then we made a
deterministic decision based on that
test statistic and we're going to
replace this with a randomized test so
why randomize test is gonna do the same
thing basically as our soft clamps
tested before but now instead of using
the clamp of likelihood we're using
their actual of likely ratio
and the main theorem in this section is
that the Hellinger distance of PN and QN
is exactly the advantage of his test
here
scissors are too hard to prove so let's
take the time to go through this so
remember the problem given some database
ax the probability about putting P was
by definition this ratio here and a lot
likelihood ratio was exactly the log of
P an of x over Q an of X so I can
rewrite this in terms of these square
roots here okay now my advantage is this
thing here the true positive minus the
false positive and so by definition this
first term is the probability that you
came from P times the probability output
P and this term is probably your output
you came from Q minus the probability
you output P and we can rearrange this
to get exactly the square of the
distance between the square roots of
these two things and this is exactly the
Hellinger distance between p.m. and qm
so why is this important so when it kind
of explains why are the Hellinger
distance comes from in this problem but
also it says the be sample the non
private sample complexity of this soft
book likelihood test is 1 over the hell
on your distance squared of pink.you
which was our optimal sample complexity
so now this we know that this randomized
test actually has optimal sample
complexity even among non private tests
if you're interested how you go from
here to sample complexity is that the
Hellinger distance has this nice
property that you can write the
Hellinger distance of two products as
the Hellinger distance of just P and Q
so we can say from this formula if I set
M to be some constant over the hell on
your distance squared I can push this
thing as close to one as I like
okay so now I've reached this privacy
for free so now we have a randomized
test that's optimal non non private
tests and also if my log ratio is
bounded between negative epsilon epsilon
then this software like lead ratio test
is exactly the soft clamp for likely
ratio test which which proof which we
proved was differentially private so we
have a private test that's optimal among
non private tests so we get for our
private sample complexity because
automatically the same as our non pirate
said let's see under this condition but
there was that our ratio is bounded
so now we have this button part about
fictional test so P primates u Prime
member we're defined exactly so that
their ratio was always bounded between
either the negative apps xi e to the
excellent so we get privacy for free for
P prime a coupon and we've recovered
this sample complexity that we claimed
before
okay so we're going to go into our upper
bound and lower bound now any questions
before we go up so let's move on to our
upper bound
so they said we're gonna focus on the
noisy look likely ratio test so remember
our test statistic is the sum of these
clamp we clamp the lug likely ratio for
every data point and I would to rewrite
this like this now of course I don't
actually have this information so I
can't decide where the data points came
from PETA with I'm or P Prime in
particularly I don't know where they
came from P or Q and even if I did know
that I wouldn't really be able to do
this but for the purpose of the analysis
I can write this and just to remind you
P prime is this blue distribution and
keep double prime is just supported on
this
okay became the upper bank roof instant
it so this is a test statistic given a
sample from Q so it's this clamp a black
ratio plus vasya noise and we have the
same thing over here but for p and so to
prove that my test works what i really
need to prove is that this red
distribution has most of its mass less
than zero and this blue distribution is
most of its mass greater than sir
and I've drawn them as gaussians here
just for illustrative purposes we
actually don't know a lot about have it
distributed but that's kind of the main
thing we need is that they're kind of
separated and so how I can describe the
separated nests is I'm gonna have the
masses separated if the standard
deviation of this distribution is less
than the gap between the expectations
and also a standard deviation of this
distribution is less than the gap
between the expectations so I can
separate that out into three a
statements so the first one is just
coming from this term here so the
pacient have standard deviation so I
need my gap to be bigger than a constant
to just get past the fact that I'm
adding constant noise and then I also
need that both of these just both of
these random variables have standard
deviation less than B so if I choose and
large enough that all three of these
things happen then my test works and my
simple complexity is we go over that an
let's look first at characterizing this
gap so the expectation under P of this
thing is so bad
tau n of my samples fall into this first
son and they all cost me X like about 1
minus tau it of my samples full into the
second part of the sum and the
expectation of this term given your in P
prime is the KL divergence between keep
climbing keep right and similarly I can
write a similar formulation where I have
to double Prime and Q Prime and my
expectation under cube under QM is
negative epsilon tower and - why -
tallien the KL divergence in the
opposite of a cute private perspective
you happy right okay it's taking the
difference of these two things I get to
an epsilon tile from here and this
Hellinger distance term comes from the
fact that the KL divergence always
dominates the chaotic ridges so this
thing is always bigger than the
Hellinger distance squared so again this
part and now notice that what is inside
the brackets is exactly the denominator
in my sample complexity bound
ok let's go on to my variance so my
variance I can't compute as nicely
because these two terms are correlated
but I can say that my variance is less
than the square of this random variable
expected square of the random variable I
can compute this thing exactly the same
as I compute the expectation now so
talent of my samples fall and the first
thing I get x1 squared but now instead
of getting the KL divergence I get a
square on the slug likelihood ratio here
but it turns out that this thing is less
than the Hellinger distance of people I
make you friend and I'm assuming my
epsilon is less than 1 the reason that's
fine is because we know that for any
constant epsilon we get privacy for free
and that comes from the fact that we
proved earlier that you're always less
than 1 over epsilon times the non
private sample complexity ok so now I've
got that my variance is less than n
times this Fame which again is the
denominator in my sample complexity
bound I can similarly prove the same
thing for cute so I have all of these
inequalities where they're all n times
the same term in that term is the thing
in my denominator so now there's three
conditions I needed before that the gap
was bigger than a constant my sep my
variance is less than the gap squared
and this guarantees also the less than
got squared I can achieve all of those
if I set N to be some big enough
constant divided by this term here
because all of these become constants at
that point ok so if I have a sample
complexity I these distributions are
further than up a pun that I can
separate between them my test works that
is our upper bound yeah
it's one of the exactly that'll Dow here
you choose it or send it to something
that's wait always valid for 18 yeah no
say it was a function of P and Q so I
probably have it so what I did was I
computed these dotted lines which were
the minimum of e to the epsilon in is a
up sometimes one distribution the other
and tau was the bigger of these two
areas right like if they're a sort of
the connection between this and so it's
smaller than Twitter variation distance
and it can be much smaller or it can be
the same it just depends on pinky
so the next thing were to do is talk
about our lower bound so I'm going to do
for a low balance remember intuitively
before the fictional test what we said
was once you distinguished Fame P Prime
and Q Prime and P double Prime and K
double Prime
you were distinguished between pink you
so what we're gonna do is formalize this
argument that you really do have to be
able to distinguish two feet either P
prime Q prime or P double prime and
cutable remember P and Q can be written
as these mixtures of two distributions
and what I'm going to do is insert this
distribution are that agrees with P on
the second part of the mixture and
agrees with Q on the first part of the
mixture and my first claim is going to
be but if you want to distinguish Fame
thank you you really do need to be able
to distinguish st. P and R or aren't you
the southern part of my claim is that if
you want to be on the distinguished
stream PNR we need enough you need 1
over tau times the number of samples
needed to distinguish between P double
Prime and Q double Prime and similarly
for R and Q with P Prime and Q Prime ok
so that's very proof that first part
because both I have attached the
distinguishes between pink you so by
definition that means that it's
advantage must be bigger than 2/3 which
means in particular that the advantage
of this test for this vector P and R or
the advantage of the test respect to R
and Q as they bigger than 130 so that's
suppose this first thing holds that the
advantage between P n R is bigger than
130 then we need 2/3 here but actually
all the matters is it's a constant I can
amplify any constant here to get up to
2/3 and the way to see that is imagine
that I'm flipping 2 points so every time
I put in a size n database here I get a
flip of one of these two points I have
to distinguish between these two points
because their probabilities are constant
distance apart it only takes a constant
number of coin flips to determine which
quite I have which tells me whether I
have PR so I just need to increase my
sample complexity by a constant factor
to get back up to my 2/3 which says this
test works okay so we have that simple
complexity for P and Q is the minimum of
these two sample complexities
okay so the second part of the Lobeck
was going to say what it was to
distinguish between P and R so remember
P and I are these two mixtures and they
agree on the second coordinate or the
second mixture part and they disagree on
the first mixture part and suppose I
have a test the distinguishes between p
and r with n samples now I'm going to
hand weave in this part of the proof a
little bit because to make this more
formal after use a bit more machinery
than I want to setup but just bear me
bear with me through the hand waving and
if you're really interested the details
are all in the paper so imagine that I
have tau n samples from either P double
prime or Q double prime what I'm going
to do is add to that 1 minus tau n
samples from P Prime and this is the
hand waving part that this is not
exactly a sample from P but it looks a
lot like a sample from for p or q but it
looks a lot like a sample from
so just imagine that it really is a
sample from either P or Q and what I'm
gonna do is put it into my test I mean
my test comes out with P and that says
the original distribution must have been
P double right and if it comes out with
r my original distribution must have
been Q double prime so this modified
test distinguishes between P double
Prime and Q double prime with tau n
samples so what this says is the Tau it
must be bigger than my private sample
complexity between P double prime and Q
double Prime and this sample complexity
is one of her excellent repeatable
priming ketover Prime I've destroyed
support so non privately one sample
would do so privately we need one over
epsilon simplest and we can make the
same argument for boosting
distinguishing between R and Q so you
need 1 over 1 minus tau the private
sample complexity for P Prime and Q
prime which we've already said is the
Hellinger distance between P Prime and
keep pray so putting on this together we
get back sample complexities lower
bounded by the minimum of these two
terms which is exactly the sample
complexity you're claiming
so to make this famine rigorous we use
something called coupling we construct a
coupling and use a style of analysis
that was introduced in this paper by
Acharya Simon Singh and you can read
back or talk to me about it later okay
so deluge and what have we done so
remember we first started with this
non-private solution it started with a
test statistic by deterministic test we
have exactly optimal sample complexity
and sample complexity was nicely
characterized so the first thing we did
was replace this deterministic test with
a randomized test and we said this
randomized test has optimal sample
complexity we don't have the exactly
anymore we've asymptotically optimal
sample complexity okay and the main
contributions this work is this side of
the table so we modified our test
statistic so we said that what you
should do is for each data point you
should limit how much it can tell you
about whether you're in P or Q by
clamping it between negative epsilon and
absolute and then we said your test so
we have two possible tests here what we
said each of these tests had optimal
sample complexity and then we
characterized back sample complexity
this we gave this kind of and closed
form characterization
and we do a little more in the paper so
in the paper we apply this hypothesis
testing result to obtain optimal optimal
accuracy algorithms for the private
change about detection yes I know this I
was I was I'm done it any questions for
a moderate question you can go back to
the previous slide how this one come up
with a picture like this and yeah so the
main insight or the first insight um was
this characterization of the non private
setting so that this randomized test has
still has optimal sample complexity and
writing that sample complexity in terms
of the Hellinger distance it's kind of a
first step
um which said that if you did this
clamping then for this part of the
distribution you would get a private
test that hadn't optimal sample
complexity and you don't have to pay for
that city you just said this would work
basically like the optimal guess would
be private
yes but if you had this property that
the optimal Houston thought the one on
private test would also be private I
guess in some sense we we started with
the intuition even additionally that
some tests like this should be optimal
just because like how many other things
could possibly okay it's a it's a very
natural test very like to just take the
non private test limit the influence
effeminate
so here is so my intuition about it and
I'm wondering your daddy's optimal or
like epsilonv inside it's you you're
basically truncating the distribution or
the sitter is B Prime and coupon you're
telling each point though you cannot
have more influence than Epsilon I'm not
like it and you put this optimal
fracture I'm guessing this intuition yes
you can't do better so this is one of
the earlier slides to send that for
testing problems the sample complexity
for and P way differential privacy is
the same as for approximate differential
privacy um and for any notions in
between Sony well lots of kind of
stability notions so you really can't
hope to do better if you weaken your
your notion of privacy or stability
so usually for our hypothesis tests and
we have this like power and significance
of parameter would you support is set to
like one third can you say something
about the dependence on foes is that
like the black box thing yeah so we only
consider constants so I don't think
we've really studied what can happen if
you have those things to be mirrored so
if you want an arbitrarily close to one
if you want that to be a parameter that
you care about the asymptotics off and
then we do get like love of one over
that thing
mmm but it's not clear that it's the
optimal thing to get and then it
actually comes up in the change point
detection problem where that really is a
parameter that you care about and so if
that parameter is constant then we get
optimal things all right it's not
constant that it's not like that what we
do
a question about the operational will we
know tell you to study like is it the
divergence if extensive operation all
right it has a name I call the
hockey-stick divergence it does not
appear to be very common but it is and
so much' correct me if it's wrong but if
you're considering being cute just like
the privacy parameters of happening like
P or Q and then it is the biggest or the
smallest Delta that makes that operation
differentially private which is maybe
one way of thinking about it but it's a
II it may be a divergence went on a
short it is something we're sort of
interested in because it kind of comes
up the smallest thing you can cut off
the two distributions so that the
remaining parts will be bounded
likelihood ratios that's why you yeah
like it's like the minimum thing you
plan to satisfy that
I think Marco has used this I think
that's how we learn the name of it
so this tradition is also intuitively
what something like what you want to do
if you just wanted to know the
statistics he writes we can preserve as
yeah you compass about none of us test
statistic and this is more or less what
you knew except that we never so that
song would be tuning parameter that's it
but at least in privacy it makes sense
in the robustness it depends on the
scale of that log likelihoods so in this
case that you don't really care about
that the epsilon is naturally defined in
this case but it's yeah it is linked
it's it exists also in we must kiss
there is something to kind of say there
so it's not clear to epsilon so epsilon
does clamping to epsilon and negative
epsilon 1 epsilon creates a optimal test
but it's possible you could get better
constants by like waiting for something
else and in particular we need this
epsilon prime and we conjecture that you
can get rid of it up some PI which is
the one kind of efficiency can be
offered and and we've done some tests
for whether you can and make that
whether changing that parameter makes I
get it's better constants
any other questions so actually I have a
question so you started with a very
simple example and practical example
that we see even in use every day people
talk about you know how likely for you
know what boy is the percentage of those
will be voting for Democrats right so
basing your results if I'm a survey
station I'm you know designing my survey
and what does this tell you about how
big of a sample going me to collect in
order to answer the question you posed
in the beginning so practical
implication yes thank you for that
survey results we have our X metonic and
yeah so if you really care about
constants what you do practically I you
would really want to explore what that I
suspect the optimal test would be a
clamping but it's not there that would
be epsilon or epsilon right and our
sample complexity again is asymptotic so
if you were talking about finite samples
then it's unclear little bit you would
this really tells you what you should do
but you know this is not a speaking at
some point even when we talk about small
samples that people who like to do this
I know I don't want to put you in a spot
it's actually maybe a good segue to
remind everyone that we have a panel set
up for tomorrow afternoon and one of the
questions for the panelists does have to
do and how we report to the statistical
results especially with the constraints
user privacy so something like this will
be a good perhaps example or something
like this but may be good for everyone
to think about more generally the main
questions for the panel is first what do
we mean by the science of data
Alyce's and the second question has to
do with how does the how do the
theoretical results both statistical
theoretical results and theoretical
results from computer science literature
translate into applied methodological a
settings especially when you have
privacy constraints so how do we go from
these type of results basically to the
question that I just asked her and how
do we communicate this with researchers
and how do we make this practical right
and then we have some very specific
specific questions I think what we'll do
maybe tonight we'll email those couple
of questions to everyone in case you
want to contribute in any way you're
welcome to send some questions ahead of
time but for now we'd like to thank god
you're once again